c'est vrai que je pense que l'un des
bases que devoir accepter la gauche
c'est que le monde est chaotique le
monde élite et eugène et le monde est
conçu de différents systèmes de pouvoir
qui sont relativement indépendants les
uns des autres qui sont pas
nécessairement relié entre il faut
toujours penser par système on est de
gauche on va penser individuellement il
faut pas penser en termes de bavures
d'individus il faut bien sûr penser des
systèmes de pouvoir dont il s'agit de
transformer le fonctionnement pour
essayer de diminuer les effets de
pouvoir qu'il fait peser sur les
individus mais en même temps le risque
de la pensée par système qui est très
très puissante à gauche c'est d'essayer
de rester une forme de cohérence et de
globalité du monde qui en fait éloigne
de la possibilité de toute
transformation et qui fait qu'il ya une
logique perverse du discours de
politique où on croit qu'on est d'autant
plus fort commentant généralité or en
fait tout le monde en généralité moins
on sait pourquoi les témoins c'est quoi
des faits on sait quoi faire
et moi je pense que je pensais de gauche
et puissante quand elle peut identifier
des mesures concrètes à prendre et les p
et les mettre en place pour transformer
des systèmes de poudre et on doit très
très bien aller mouvement par exemple
sur sur la police ou sur la question des
quartiers populaires dont moi aussi
beaucoup impliqué alors je suis en même
temps d'accord avec cette analyse en un
sens mais qui vont dire voilà ce n'est
pas seulement la question des quartiers
populaires se passe quand la police
élections du colonialisme c'est
l'impérialisme c'est le genre c'est le
racisme etc
c'est de l'état capitaliste l'état
impérialiste en fait vous dit comme ça
si vous voulez régler la problème de la
mise à mort des jeunes garçons des
quartiers populaires par la police vous
devez défaire l'impérialisme occidental
le racisme le colonialisme
vous avez de montée en généralité mais
de façon tellement abstraite qu'à la fin
vous pouvez plus rien faire parce que
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si jamais
vous devez des plantes et de l'état
colonialiste et impérialiste pour qu
adama traoré ne meurt pas la rue ferai
jamais donc il va continuer à mourir
dans un fait c'est une manière de montée
en généralité qui fait croire qu'on se
donne du pouvoir alors vrai qu'on se dé
possède une capacité d'action concrète
sur les mesures ou les techniques sont
responsables de la mise à mort d'un
certain nombre de gens et donc je crois
qu'effectivement il faut que la gauche
trompe avec un certain recours aux
abstractions incantatoire aux
attractions vide aux abstractions
purement discursive en vérité qui permet
de se faire applaudir et d'apparaître
comme radical pourrait en fait être
beaucoup plus radicale parce que tu
radical s'est transformé les choses et
ça n'est pas rée se faire plaisir et se
faire applaudir par ceux qui vous end
avance
oui
[Musique]